ich wollte das alles nicht ich bin ja
echt nur um zu helfen gegangen man soll
die figur von der frau nicht erkennen
was sinnvoll ist eigentlich dann sieht
man auch keine kalaschnikow du hast ein
kind großgezogen das anderen menschen
das leben nimmt oder oder die
massakriert oder so
[Musik]
für uns war das normal hinrichtung war
normal hand absteigen war normal
ich war immer dabei meine erste leiche
gesehen habe waren mit 2 1 nach 23
monaten da war 17 jähriger junge
der wurde dann eher hang war seine
ehefrau vergewaltigt hat zb und die dann
auch umgebracht hat ich fand das nicht
schlimm ich find das jetzt auch nicht
schlimm aber ich fand es interessant die
das aussehen
[Musik]
mein therapeut habe mir gesagt wäre
besser wenn ich mir einen hund holen
damit ich auch mehr ausgehe
soziale kontakte noch gleich bekommen so
halt bisher rausgehen und ich habe so
eine paranoia
ich weiß nicht ich mag das nicht unter
menschen zu sagen früher war das anders
jetzt das extrem geworden fesche
einkaufen ist ganz schlimm und am
menschen in der stadt ist ganz schlimm
gegen vom café sitzen ist auch für mich
ist das was vier
normal ist es ziemlich schwer also
generell ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
recht hoch dass solche menschen
traumatisiert sind
die wahrscheinlichkeit ist recht hoch
dass die unterstützung brauchen werden
auch professionelle unterstützung
das sind menschen die aus ganz
unterschiedlichen individuellen gründen
dahin geraten sind wo sie hin geraten
sind und wo wir für hier und jetzt
letztlich auch die mann angefallen
werden wir uns immer wieder frage konnte
die personen nur was war denn da los und
so weiter und so fort
entscheidend ist eigentlich diese person
ist jetzt hier
wir wollen dieser personen jetzt helfen
und was können wir tun damit es ihr
besser geht
[Musik]
dann die stoffbahn auch kollegen als ich
bei meinem haus am arbeiten
denken sie waren anderen haus am
arbeiten naja war sie mit einem hells
angels zusammen sie ist halt in die
prostitution tod eingegangen
und es war eine
ein schönes schein beziehung war
geschmack
wir haben uns darüber ausgetauscht dass
wir für gäste hatten was sie für wünsche
hatten haben uns auch darüber lustig
gemacht weil es eine komische wünsche
es ist einfach so standard ist
standardpreis extrawünsche kosten extra
ein tag hat sie mich angerufen ich war
für drei stunden
wir haben uns kaputtgelacht solide was
für 34
ich hatte so ein scheiß verschieden
da hat mir dazu erklärt dass sie den
heiraten musste weil sonst konnten die
nix machen ja und nach drei stunden
haben sie sich entweder geschrieben und
das geschäft zu ende am ende ging es
also man hat einfach gemerkt übt ihr
nicht gut weil sie war am ende auf 48
kilo gelagert
er hat sie geschlagen et cetera
angelogen und sie wollte das nicht mehr
mitmachen und sie wollte flüchten
[Musik]
also dem mario habe ich gefunden auf
facebook es gibt ja verschiedene gruppen
dort und da wurde ein bild von ihm
gepostet und da ich wusste dass er in
syrien ist und ich dort helfen wollte
habe ich ihn angeschrieben
also erstmal muss man sagen dass der es
stärker als die atheistische gruppen
zuvor frauen angezogen und rekrutiert
hat und er hat dann zum ersten mal auch
gesagt wir brauchen eben nicht nur
männer
wir brauchen nach wie vor kämpfe aber
wir brauchen auch krankenschwestern wir
brauchen lehrerin wir brauchen die
mütter der nächsten generation unser
kämpfer das war zum ersten mal dass eine
jihadistische organisation explizit auch
das narrativ auf frauen ab gerichtet hat
deswegen haben wir eben gesehen in
deutschland aber auch in anderen
westlichen staaten das ab 2014 also wo
das kalifat dann entstanden es dass ab
2014 dann unglaublich viele frauen
gegangen sind
[Musik]
ich habe wirklich nichts von der das
alles so kommen
ich habe ihn auch erst eigentlich war
ich ja wusste dass männer und frauen im
islam ist dass er bei uns auch
eigentlich so aus haan fast und so sehr
extrem
ja ich gesagt habe ich dich was fragen
habe ich erst auf eine antwort gewartet
dann hat das schon so angefangen hatte
gesagt ja da hab ich gefragt ich wollte
rüber kommen und zu helfen hatte gesagt
aber wenn du kommst ist es nicht so
einfach als unverheiratete frau dabei
der aber ehrlich dann wirst du in ein
frauenhaus kommen und bist du heiratest
kommst du dann nicht raus und da habe
ich ihn gefragt bist so frey leiter der
gesagt nein hab ich sage okay dann
heiraten wird
[Musik]
die heute als ich habe das erste mal
gesehen habe und dann hat mit seiner
waffe und am ganzen militär angezogen
und der bart war schön
bei treffen kann man sich vorstellen
dass das relativ schnell positiv
wahrgenommen werden kann man waffen
können sicherheit bieten waffen können
stärker ausdrücken
man muss war von auch nicht unbedingt
als bedrohlich wahrnehmen es gibt in
einigen staaten fühlt man es sogar
sicherer wenn soldaten mit waffen auf
der straße sind dieses umfeld von gewalt
von waffen von krieg da gibt es eben
menschen die das für sich auch als kick
wahrnehmen können und die dann auch
diesen kick in ähnlicher art und weise
dann suchen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
was mich an der grenze ein mädchen
abgeholt hat da hat er zu mir gesagt du
kannst dich anziehen was ich ja ganz
komisch fand da habe ich mich angeguckt
wie jetzt ich bin ja angezogen hat sie
aus dem kopf verbannt rausgeholt
dazugehört normale rosas iran hat sich
so ein rocker dann ziehst du deinen
primat angewandt dann ziehst du dir
deine hand schorn und dann kommt noch
dein gesicht steuer dran
da sieht man gar nichts drunter
hauptmann dick denn das ist ja wirklich
auch der sinn davon dass man solche
gewänder an zieht man soll die figur von
der frau nicht erkennen was sinnvoll ist
eigentlich dann sieht man auch keine
kalaschnikow dann war erstmal so ein
riesen stacheldraht aus stacheldraht zum
zaun da mussten wir ja rübergehen und
aber einfach knie hände alles war offen
und dann sind wir erstmal gerannt weil
die türken an der grenze haben wir auch
angefangen auf uns zu schießen aus meist
nicht das ist wie diese propaganda
videos man sieht hört aber mal
realisiert ist nicht man hat todesangst
aber man will weg da man was willst du
machen stehen bleiben da denkst du nicht
mal dran
man realisiert das nicht man hat angst
ja aber man rennt ich glaube deswegen
stolpern auch so viel in so filmen ja
[Musik]
wenn ich mit überzeugen dort hingegangen
für den islam für die schade ja das
heißt für den ist für das islamische
gesetz da für die sachen wofür es glaube
ich dafür gegangen wäre ich glaube ich
nicht so mental emotional als weg weil
ich bin dorthin gegangen ohne etwas zu
wissen ich wollte nicht nur den kindern
helfen was ich meine ist
ich wollte das alles nicht ich bin ja
echt nur um zu helfen gegangen also
kinder zwölf das erste mal dass er
volles motiv klar das denke ich wird
auch weltweit und für alle kulturellen
hintergründe so gelten aber vor ort
spätestens ist davon nichts mehr übrig
also die die wenigsten
ich habe noch nie von welchen gehört die
da irgendwie als krankenschwestern oder
ähnliches arbeiten konnten
aber dann so gefährlich angesehen hier
ist hier in deutschland das waren auf
einmal einen terroristin ist das auf
einer wohnungsdurchsuchung und wohnung
stürmen wo waffen auf das gehalten
werden wurde dann echt als terroristen
abgestempelt ich will das nicht das war
noch nie mainz und ich kann das auch
nicht
ich kann das auch nicht
[Musik]
fro einfach nur wieder dazu ja gott sei
dank so kannst du dein leben leben
[Musik]
ich kann mich noch erinnern als die
whatsapp kam heißt es von mario gehört
oder ich hab mir immer geschrieben
mohammed für dich und sie dann nein
ja hab was gehört von mario so gab es
noch während ich das gelesen boxclever
kommen mario es hat doch immer mit mario
kommt nicht mehr kommt nicht mehr also
während ich das gelesen habe fand ich
das so so ganz seltsam
[Musik]
aber es ist einfach grauenhaft in kind
zu verlieren es grauenhaft auf diese art
und weise und überhaupt ein kind
verlieren ist schlimm
du hast ein kind großgezogen der
eventuell andere menschen das leben
nimmt oder oder sie massakriert oder so
also für mich weil waren die jahren
albtraum und jetzt ist der albtraum noch
noch stärker weil ich diesen tod nicht
begreife
[Musik]
ketten von den decken hängen da wo leute
gefoltert wurden blut an den decken und
das war auch alles in ordnung bis er
dann von einer drohne getroffen wurde
nach zwei monaten und er dann auch
gestorben ist wo ich mir denke bord habe
ich einblick mit männern
da waren viele leute glaube ich im auto
mit handschellen gefesselt wo er drauf
gedrückt hat er hat die bombe zu zünden
gebracht und der junge war vier oder
fünf er weiß auch nicht was er macht
also wenn ich die chance hätte irgendwas
anders zu machen würde ich nichts anders
machen
[Musik]